hey guys how's it going so today we're
gonna be doing a super simple just very
chill laid-back ask IJ episode so I
asked you guys on Twitter for some
questions and the first question that I
saw is Eric wants to know what happened
to my theme song it's still here I guess
we should probably queue it up the
second question I'm going to answer
because it is what I called this video
and I'm sure many of you are wondering
thanks to Tim for asking this question
when is the last time that I use Windows
what's my fascination with Apple it
seems you get a much powerful PC for
less you're right you can get a much
more inexpensive more powerful computer
but what you're not getting is Mac OS I
love the Mac operating system it's
beautiful it works seamlessly for
everything that I need to do I'm a
designer I edit video I do a lot of
graphics I do a lot of things with
photography Apple is made for that this
is not new information granted most of
the things that I do use you could also
use on a PC the entire Adobe suite but I
edit in Final Cut Pro so that would
prove to be a little bit of an issue
because I can't edit Final Cut Pro on a
PC the look of Apple products they are
absolutely stunning to that point though
Microsoft and many other computing
companies are stepping up their game
because they have to we want things that
look great but also work great that's
the very first question when was the
last time I used Windows and probably 45
minutes ago
I've PC right there I just downloaded
Diablo 3 I used to be absolutely
obsessed with Diablo 3 or whenever it
first came out and I'm worried about
what's gonna happen if I start playing
again so I guess to answer your question
with what my fascination is with Apple I
don't think it's a fascination
necessarily they had always done things
differently ad will change the music
industry single-handedly with the iPod
and the integration of iTunes for me
starting at a young age we always had
Apple computers at our house so I didn't
know anything else when I was younger
that's what I used and when I went to
school and started using Windows
computers I was like there's a whole
other world
there that I didn't even know about and
not only windows time that I installed
Linux on one of my old old Macs asked
like this is incredible
grand I didn't really use Linux that
much but it was something that even at a
young age it sort of opened my eyes to
open source and how many other things
that are out there and not just Apple
with all that being said I'm not a
windows hater I actually have a very fun
unboxing coming up probably hopefully in
the next week or so when I get back into
town I am so excited about it if you've
been following me on Instagram or
Twitter you might have saw something on
there that will give you a hint as to
what it is actually the thing look at
the way Justine looks while cutting a 40
pounds of chocolate everyone should be
terrified Jerry wants to know what's the
worst piece of tech that I still use
today it's probably a wired mouse this
is not it clearly it looks like I don't
use it just recently had my entire
office ripped apart because I had a leak
in my roof so I still haven't fixed
everything back up but here it is this
is my baby one of my favorites guys here
that are they coming to take me away I
guess I'll take this opportunity to
brush my hair
there's a little glitter outside my
house let's carry on who's my favorite
racer in Mario Kart definitely toad
what's happenin are you looking for
somebody
you're beautiful you're a beautiful dog
this is actually great Colton says what
do you think of this giant Matty and
that actually does look like him
look over here hey no the other way that
look this way see they can see you I
really wish this helicopter would go
away OCP de lo this video is going
really well isn't it Oh Mac Owosso wants
to know what I'm listening to you on
audible this month and this is a my dear
friend a Lilly Singh it's her new book
that just came out how to be a boss
clearly there's some sort of invasion
happening outside right now I did start
actually reading it to the a in the log
pages and it is a beautiful book so if
you do not have this book you need to
get it in one form or another Lilly is
one of those people that is by far the
most hardest-working youtuber did I've
ever met I don't think she sleeps I
don't know how she does all the things
that she does with her new book you'll
be able to find out how to also be a
boss if you want to get Lilly's book or
any other book you can check out my link
below audible.com slash iJustine where
you guys can get a 30 day free trial and
also a free book so this could be yours
or you could get my book if you have it
listen to it already let me know a book
you guys get audible.com slash iJustine
I seriously just audible is one of those
things that I've actually started
listening to while I play Zelda so it
actually makes me feel like I'm being
sort of productive because I'm learning
some sort of information while also
playing a video game I think that's what
I'm telling myself and that's what I'm
telling you so that you can tell
yourself George wants to know how I
became friends with ROH so crazy enough
ROH actually made a blackops cake years
and years ago and she tweeted it to me I
was blown away with how amazing the cake
was and I was like
girl is awesome this I followed her on
Twitter subscribe to our YouTube channel
and not only is she an incredible
youtuber but she's funny and cute it's
just awesome fangirl moment hashtag girl
love we've also done so many fun collabs
together that I made a playlist of it so
I'll put that link in the description
also and an annotation so you guys can
go check out all the videos that we've
done not only on my channel but on hurts
scold me whenever I'm playing Zelda
still I am still playing but it's nice
because since I beat the game I'm just
playing it like a casual normal level
that feels healthy whereas before I was
playing so much that I felt I felt
worried I was worried about my health
Gavin it was no I feel about the man in
this gym and that man is Jim Carrey I
love Jim care I love him so much like I
just I'm speechless how much time do I
spend editing versed filming well for
this video for example I thought it was
gonna be a super quick turn on the
camera start chatting but I have a
feeling as I'm started chatting and how
many times I messed up and had to start
over this is probably gonna be a five or
six or seven hour edit depending how
many times I get sidetracked so it can
take a very long time but I actually
really enjoy editing I love to edit I
think it's so much fun to sort of piece
together and sort of tell a story out of
whatever it is that I had just filmed
editing vlogs are probably my favorite
thing even though I feel like those are
not the most viewed thing in my channel
I hope that people enjoy them because
they are one of my favorite things to do
I'm kind of trying to find a creative
way to make mundane things that I do on
a daily basis seems sort of interesting
it's not easy it's not easy at all but I
like that challenge and it's fun I like
doing silly fun things and filming it
for you guys the bad ones know what it's
like to be unchopped the I didn't know I
was on chopped you can watch a rerun it
was on me a celebrity tournament it was
the web stars edition it was actually so
much fun I had an incredible time
everyone on set was so awesome and it
was really fun to sort of be in this
professional kitchen with professional
things like everything was they'd have
family ice cream makers the deep fryers
and I was there just like oh god where's
the blender and I didn't even end up
using the blender I had so much fun and
what I do it again yes yes I would
definitely fearful what would have
happened on the second round because I
don't know I think I could have done it
I thought I did a really good job on my
appetizer
either way I'm sure you can find it on
demand or on reruns because you guys
have been tweeting me every time it's on
and it seems to be on quite a lot well
that's it guys I will see you in my next
video I'm sorry this is sort of just a
random one I don't even know what the
heck what's going on they probably put
should have put like a little bit of
makeup on cuz I've got this screen over
here that's what I'm looking at and I
was like wow I'm feeling it like that
got a little sunburn today I went
outside can you believe it I went
outside god this is such an incredible
this monitor is beautiful
I love it so crisp anyway I'll see you
guys later
[Music]